mais côté ses propos c'est tout ce que
je combats c'est tout ce que je combats
c'est du communautarisme c'est nier nos
fêtes calendaires
cetc se replier sur une communauté
religieuse regrettait alors moi je j'ai
été déçu parce que jamais je n'avais
entendu gims
commune à communautariser son discours
je les appelais je le lui ai dit qu'elle
fait déjà répondu a dit qu'il était
désolé qu'il voulait blesser personne
qu'il allait souhaiter bonne année à
tout le monde je pense qu'il ne voulait
pas baisser mais pour moi ce discours
est un discours qu'on doit combattre
c'est un discours séparatiste et je ne
peux pas faire autrement que de le
condamner et de le lui dire en face
alors c'est pas de réponse de ben ali
sans hystérie alors sans hystérie puis
ouais c est plutot qu alors juliette mon
soir c'est un bonne année à tous merci
direct à une bonne année
le charisme est sûr c'est que c'est pas
m
merci d'être avec nous alors déjà sur la
déclaration valérie pécresse où elle a
eu raison de dire ça oui il a eu tout à
fait raison après le choix mes yeux ça
n'a aucune valeur elle a été bien
contente de le financer à travers la
région ile-de-france folle des années
alors qu'il avait déjà eu des propos et
des paroles dans ses textes absolument
problématique à ce moment là était bien
content que maintenant le scandale a
explosé donc à laisser aller c'est de
sauver les meubles donc oui c'était la
moindre des syriens peau si on n'essaie
rien passé non non rien non non alors il
paraît qu'on voulait alors raymond lundi
soir il est revenu sur cette affaire de
bonne année et regardez le coup de
gueule de raymond qui vous a énervé
parce qu'il avait poussé un coup de
gueule lorsqu'on avait évoqué le sujet
dans l'émission lundi regarde là où
raymond ce que tu vas voir à l'antenne
c'est toi c'est vrai
qu'avec des couilles c'est qui tient ce
week end à dire du jour je romps exact
on va écrire à la raison c'est vrai
qu'on joue dans les baronnies
voilà j'ai tout ça à ouadhias gros mais
ce critère est ouverte et voilà qu'avec
l'argent et ça risque et la numéro près
avec celle acquise aujourd'hui il fane
et berson lui arrive à la cheville
aujourd'hui et personne à remplacer
diam's côté rap féminin comment voyager
aussi des jets elle fut arrêtée là mais
le show mais l'a dit j'arrête c'est pas
ma vie dit bravo maladie qui coupait
l'herbe a dit m moi je suis fan c'est le
symbole extraordinaire
alors juliette sata papus ah non ça va
faire réaliser immédiatement il fait
froid dans le dos en fait si vous voulez
le truc c'est que je comprends
exactement ce que vous vouliez dire par
là je comprends que vous vouliez mettre
en lumière les incohérences de maître
gims et on peut même moi ça me fait
marrer mais le problème justement c'est
que je pense que vous prenez pas la
mesure de vos mots quand vous dites ça
c'est que vous dites diam's elle au
moins elle a eu les couilles le courage
sais pas quelle mouche vous avez gisent
émergent les grues sont intelligents de
d'être une bonne musulmane elle est bas
elle a ruiné sa carrière elle s'est
voilée de la tête aux pieds elle est
partie en arrêt mais saoudite la cuisine
la course côtière tout le tralala et
vous vous trouvez ça génial et tout le
monde sur le plateau applaudit donc
qu'est ce que vous êtes en train de dire
aux jeunes femmes de confession
musulmane france aujourd'hui pour être
une bonne musulmane et avoir la
légitimité de parler à voir la lune et y
sont relatifs à la liberté aujourd'hui
c'est bien joué de sa part mais médiane
ce qu'est ce qui est arrivé à diam's
il pas à célébrer moi quand je vois ça
ça me terrorise ses 300 mais si elle est
heureuse comme ça mais c'est bien tout
ça c'est de l'hypocrisie parce que je
connais pas beaucoup de parcelles à
cette table et vous me répondre
honnêtement si c'était à votre fille que
ça arrivait
c'est votre fille qui se convertit à
l'islam elle mène du ruel bromont arabie
saoudite mais sais pas si c'est son
choix essentiels de ressources ag2l
c'est une folie ce que vous dites j'ai
une fille si jamais se convertit à
l'islam ce sera son choix bien sûr son
choix et si elle est et si elle est
heureuse avec un voile ce sera son choix
comme plein de jeunes femmes dans la rue
qui viennent me dire merci de nous
soutenir parce que le voile c'est notre
choix ont défini leur dire regardez là
les préceptes chaque jour
quitté répondent elles avaient été
trouvés sa carrière s'est emparé crs
oasis est ce qu elle je vais te dire
juliette elle avait tout elle avait tout
diam's elle était la numéro bien sûr ils
avaient de l'argent elle et y apparaît
donc c'était elle était plus heureuse
comme ça oui et admettons qu'elle ait
choisi ce que je ne pense pas perdre
patience
à rien mais c'est pas la peine va faire
la promotion 4 une bonne musulmane
contrairement à l'or moi je vous invite
lui même en train de vie occidental eh
ben elle au moins diane tell a eu les
couilles de deux courses qu'elle a fait
son stage je vous invite à quand l
organe d une émission vous invite à
regarder et surtout ce qui est important
c'est écoutez j'ai jamais parlé de
carrière ruinée jamais belle attendez
attendez je vous ai sépare des prix bien
sûr j'ai jamais parlé de carrière ruinée
j'ai dit elle est partie quand elle
était au top en quoi j'ai parlé de la
rhune j'ai jamais parlé d'arabie
saoudite vous me parlez d'arabie seule
escale et attendez je vous ai parlé
comme un coupable bon j'ai pas parlé
d'arabie saoudite non et vous avez dit
un truc vous êtes c'est terrifiant moi
ce que j'entends de terrifiant ce que
vous avez dit expliquez-moi
couscoussière ces points-là
couscoussière nationale est vrai que ça
c'est péjoratif de dire à des partis qui
avait parlé de
village
aura tout vu mais pourrait dire les
propos de raymond choqué voilà ce qui me
choque c'est un pas dix secondes que
vous êtes là où sortait à peine du
maquillage et des pépites au vous parler
de
ces pépites oui on fait la conduisit
souvient de ce concert c'est quoi la ou
les grosses productions
oui juste venir j'aurais gaza a voté oui
mais juste venir pour manger des gâteaux
c'est quoi ce que c'est mais
qu'avez-vous c'était juste une blague
c'est ça qui est grave cette histoire
le mécanisme de geeks le labour cas de
diane s'éteint et franchement quand je
vois la salle et
kasserine soit de la voir un jour c'est
ce qu'a fait diam's les convictions sens
à peu près d'accord alors ça veut dire
sur ça vous dit quelque chose de
diabolique à la bbc quand vous parlez de
votre fille et que monsieur verdez me
disais si ma fille c'est ce choix là je
le respectais si votre fille fait le
choix comme un fait diam's demain de se
mettre en burqa et de et de renier son
mode de vie occidental elle vous dit
avoue que son vote de votre mode de vie
occidental avoue n'est plus compatible
avec ces valeurs aujourd'hui on vient
aux actes et les solides convictions
c'est un choix
sage empêche de vivre est ce que diable
ça mais un camion devant chez vous tous
les matins pour empêcher de vivre c'est
celle envie de vivre salle rit laissez
la vivre sa vie arrêtez de les traiter
de couscous hier en déjà vous blessez
l'abissa lui
alors
[Applaudissements]
j'aime pas bien évidemment
tu as
les aider
non ne suis pas venu pour pour agresser
diane je suis venu pour reprocher à vous
ce que vous avez dit sur une plage à
jour qu'est-ce que j'ai désirent donner
la promotion de l'islamisation
j'ai fait la promotion de 15 4 yards et
fournir semaines et là c'est bien une
version
cd rien on les 3 a laissé derrière lui
des succès louis
elle a écrit un bouquin que j'ai lu avec
des mots explique tout le cheminement ne
s'est pas posé les dix ans et n'a pas
fait de promotion bien sûr non non non
elle a fait de la pub pour rien excuser
moi pour le coup et vous dites est vous
qui n'utilisait jamais dit que c'est une
bonne musulmane mais n'avait dit alors
tu veux la donner
et donc adapter un choix de vie c'est
son choix et elle a fait seul a expliqué
pendant 350 pages avec son bouquin
croyez-vous en cause et droite
confondues pour parler de dia mais
moi j'ai près de 6 vous
guidant talent avec des scies à poil
dans techniques et tous
avec des fans n'en sais que les dés tout
eh ben elle mélanie diam's elle a eu le
courage d'aller jusqu'au bout de ses
convictions il donne de renier son maire
d'argentât là c'est en fait la serre ça
me paraît quand même là c'est un
dialogue de sourds en fait raymond tu
fais semblant de pas fait semblant mais
oui c'est qu'elle est en train de dire
tout sympa l'ordre ensuite j'ai pas
compris sur un fait en fait justement je
pense que tu peux être musulmane avoir
le courage d'avoir tes convictions mais
continuer quand même ta carrière
continue et dès
que je veux dire non vraiment c'est pas
avoir plus de courage que de se retirer
quand on était au sommet c'est pas
forcément ça le courage la bassine le
coin pour moissac se met à côté de la
place énormément
complètement à côté de la plaque on
pardon reprend depuis le début et
essayez d'écouter parce que c'est
compliqué si vous essayez pas d'écouté
on parle de maitre gims qui rentre sur
un débat religieux des fêtes de bonnes
années de jouer noël il veut pas qu'on
lui souhaite jouer noël il veut pas
qu'on lui donne du bonheur ensuite je
dis si tu veux pas tout ça parce que
c'est pas dans tes convictions de
religion ta religion elle te dis que tu
ne dois pas chanter ta religion elle te
dis que tu ne dois pas te faire des
cigares dans la bouche ta religion tu te
dis que tu dois pas mettre des femmes
nues si tu veux faire ça fait comme
diam's si tu veux aller dans l'évolution
du coût de ces biens qui ont été au bout
de ces regards des mois comprend
pourquoi pas ce qui l'excité exactement
ce que je réponds cesse vous dis tu veux
faire c'est répéter que j'aurais dit
attendez vous verrez que soit la
religion et gims ne l'est pas
l'essor de
cm2 est en train d'opposer et d'essayer
de faire croire oui notre montrer du
doigt des bons musulmans et des mauvais
musulmans sa part du tout ski tout ce
qui va mal ça combinant il a dit tout le
mal qu'il a dit qu'il y avait des gens
qui étaient de confession musulmane dont
la conviction était celle là et que cela
allait jusqu'au bout de leur démarche
est allé et est allé faire comme on l'a
mais ça ne voulait pas dire que pour les
autres qui ne font pas ce choix là ce
sont des mauvais musulmans c'est pas de
la maison des chats 15 de jacques chirac
arrive bientôt à
10,7 réciter ses matches aux samoa ce
week-end le léchage de la religion prend
à peu près je vois la potée lui dont les
miens et il ya des gens qui co qui eux
ce qui leur convient c'est d'ailleurs ce
que cette omission est au bout des
textes qui vient qui est agité son choix
personne
il faudrait retirer deux sous
l'étiquette
tu ne peux pas dire que je suis pour la
totale liberté ya un instant tu viens
dire à gilles ouais pourquoi les femmes
sont voilées pourquoi diam's est ce
voile oui je regrette si ta fille elle
serait comme ça si elle était jeune et
pas pour la totale tu n'es pas pour la
totalité
il faut juste dire que ne boudera pas
des mots que tu que qui sont en
contradiction avec toi laisse youtube
prône la totale liberté c'est ma vraie -
car je ne te gêne pas elles conviennent
au soir me gêne à alors tu n'es pas par
la totale liberté puisque abbas y avait
environ
message d'objets message que ça envoie
un message dans pureté et qui me gêne
profondément pour lui ça lui fait peur
mais non bien sûr
française elle ne ressemble plus à une
française avec elle
portrait
[Musique]
c'est honteux je le voulais
vous avez devant vous allez matte ont
voulu déterminer qui sont les roues les
mauvais musulmans c'est vous c'est vous
la qui stigmatise et qui sont les bons
et mauvais français on est français on
n'est pas parce qu'on porte un voile ou
pas mais arrêter mal les gens sont en
train de baisser un jour possède je vous
le souhaite nous serait heureuse et
beaux jours mais quoi cette semaine
c'est le bonheur qui fait là des jurés
longs mois ce sont les mailles peau
crise a surpris au départ la démarche de
diama surprise alors on était chauds
merde
on a été soufflé ce qui est important
c'est qu'elle ne fasse pas de
prosélytisme ou lisa le débat aurait
lieu ce avec art urbain imposé à faire
des choix
ça c'est autre chose et auquel
elle a le droit pour elle ce serait
ennuyeux c'est et si effectivement elle
été radicalisé c'est plus du
prosélytisme et c'est pas le nave pas de
quoi alors
et vous avez-vous vu dans quel rôle
diam's aller parader ténor pas du tout
et non pour vous ça c'est pas une femme
résidant en arabie séoudite parce que
les français sont trop méconnu mais on
voulait changer de vie et oui avant nous
servir de tout et n'importe quoi pour
taper sur les musulmans le film d'arthur
canada
mais avant de vous servir de tout et
n'importe quoi pour taper sur l'islam le
voile et ses rangs ces niveaux un
minimum ça n'a rien à voir avec la
france sa décision ce qui l'a rendue
malheureuse c'est le succès l'argent la
médiatiser a refusé dans la religion y
trouve notamment maurice on va taxer les
gens c'est insupportable j'avais déjà
fait un triomphe vous n'êtes pas très
par exemple j'aurais mange ici j'ai pas
la force vous êtes patriotes donc vous
aimez votre patrie mais la france oui
j'aime la france quand elle rit quand
elle est française mais voilà mais davos
en quatre ans
nous soient sains pour moi la burqa ne
représente pas les valeurs de féminité
dans les années blanches d'aller voir
des clubs bva
[Applaudissements]
blanche alors est-ce que vous me
racontez alors arrêtez ce que vous dites
axonais il vient de me dire vous voulez
mais la france que quand les blancs
je te donne la parole mais tais toi
qu'est ce que voulait dire pour moi que
je vous ai alors que je n'aime pas du
tout pas demain la france ça doit être
toute blanche bien blanc voilà c'est ça
c'est ça je ne ressemblais arrêt du
blanc l'on regarde moi pour vous je suis
là pour ça pour vous moucher la france
mais bien sûr vous avez vu je vous ai je
vous ai vu fêter la galette des rois
n'ya pas le plus de dix minutes j'ai
trouvé tête surtout pour fera cadeau
père de beinheim une citation une
montagne à un juste pour finir après
j'arrête si tu dis bon jeu fini parce
que tyler s'est interrompue tu dis tu es
patriotes thème la france puisque tout
c'est ton pays il n'y a pas de problème
mais ça roule reste quatrième avec
plaisir mais aussi j'aime la france
olympique moi on est poussé à cette
règle se dérangent puisque raison de
plus elle s'est barrée en arabie
saoudite elle est même plus là alors à
la revue oui je trouvais ça très bien
merci à toi même cas là on a la
meilleure elle aurait dû y rester voilà
je sais pourquoi tu es venu ce soir là
c'est vrai agressivité
parmi eux on laisse comprends pas quand
je donne la parole on n'a pas entendu
bernard est là je crois qu'il faut pas
stigmatiser comme vous le faites les
musulmans il ya un très beau texte qui
s'appelle le courant tous les musulmans
ne t'en va pas non j'ai tous les mesures
sont permis vous avez ouvert pendant 12
heures porte quoi donc je peux en dire
en place il est nerveux en ce moment
suite au choc
je n'ai pas vu beaucoup de monde
mais c'est un truc de fou à la maison il
annonce est venue elle s'est assise et
je te dis
mais le gars
s'est élevée dans les gares rebelles non
je disais simplement que le coran est un
très beau texte sais pas si vous êtes
plongé un jour dedans smiley fille sage
il ya différents courants de l'islam
dont il faut pas stigmatiser tous les
musulmans les différents chacun fait
encore en monsieur il ya un coran il ya
là bien regarder alors la bible il ya
plusieurs mois plusieurs il ya plusieurs
courants aussi dans la bible dans le
catholicisme c'est pareil oui il ya
risque pour les shows de chaque c'est la
parole de dieu et voilà mais là c'est la
presse et la parole du prophète mahomet
allez arrêter de faire des blagues
et 6 passes comme nom jusqu'à en prendre
en temps c'est bien que j'aie envie de
tout le monde n'est pas de problème il
ya les changes n'est pas très juste a
juste arrêter de dire des vannes comme
couscoussière s'affolant d et puis voilà
et puis tu vois bien et puis après pas
de problème c'était juste aller l'om en
rapport avec la radical monsieur calmez
vous vous êtes
sont pas d'actes ou téléfilm
avoué fin d'année que ce que c'est vrai
c'est pas du tout en tout cas c'est moi
je suis champion me dire tourner des
repas raclette je vais rigoler en fait
on vous dira pas
assez fragile ici un bon enfant